الى السودان حيث افاد مراسل الجزيره
بتصاعد اعمده دخان حول المنطقه الصناعيه
غربي مدينه الخرطوم ورجحت مصادر محليه
للجزيره ان يكون الدخان ناتجا عن تجدد
المعارك بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع
انه دون انفجار في جنوب مدينه ام درمان
صباح اليوم
اعلم الخرطوم مراسل الجزيره اسامه السيد
احمد اسامه اخر التطورات على الارض على
وقع
ردود الفعل من قبل طرفي الصراع في السودان
على موقف
الوسيطين الامريكي والسعودي من تعليق
المفاوضات
على الارض التطورات الميدانيه قبل الدقائق
من الان او ربما قبل ثواني يعني ظللنا
نستمع الى اصوات طلقات من اسلحه خفيفه
ومتوسطه كما ان هناك يعني قبل نحن نصف
ساعه من الان تقريبا كان هناك
انفجارات الدوين انفجارات طبعا في منطقه
جنوب الخرطوم من الاسلحه ثقيله هذه
التطورات ايضا قبل ساعتين من الان كنا
نتحدث عن تصاعد اعمده الدخان الان اذا ما
يعني سمعتم الان ايضا نستمع الى طلقات
متفرقه وغير منتظمه في منطقه وسط الخرطوم
كنا نتحدث عن تصاعد اعمده الدخان قبل نحو
ساعتين من الان ولا تزال هذه الاعمده يعني
مستمره
وبما يشير الى استمرار هذه المواجهات ما
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في
منطقه
في منطقه غرب الخرطوم في منطقه محيط
المنطقه الصناعيه هذه التطورات طبعا
مستمره
باستمرارها ايضا بحسب مصادر اكدت لنا ان
هناك حشود من قوات الدعم السريع في منطقه
العسال وبمنطقه جبل اولياء ومنطقه طيبه
وشريهان جنوب منطقه جنوب الخرطوم
بحسب مصادر اكدت لنا انه هناك يعني تحشيد
وتحشيد يعني مضاد في هذه المنطقه وتحدثت
المصادر عن ان هذا التحشيد ليس
معهودا في هذه المناطق طيله الفتره
السابقه التي شهدت فيها الاشتباكات
المباشره وغير المباشره ما بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع يعني هذه التطورات
طبعا تاتي في خضم قبل يوم واحد فقط من
انتهاء هدنه الخمسه ايام التي تم تمديدها
بعد سبعه ايام بعض المراقبين يشيرون الى
ان الهدنه
يعني يعرف منها بانها قد انهارت طالما ان
الجيش السوداني قبل ايام قد اتخذ قرارا
بتعليق مشاركته في هذه المفاوضات مفاوضات
جده برعايه المملكه السعوديه
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه وكذلك قرار
الوسيطين في المملكه السعوديه والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بتعليق هذه المفاوضات
برمتها
واشارت الوساطه طبعا انها على استعداد
لاعاده الحوار من جديد اذا ما لمست جديه
من الطرفين اذا التطورات متلاحقه ولازم
نستمع الى اصوات الطلاقات المتفرقه في
منطقه وسط الخرطوم ما يشير الى ان هناك
ربما يعني بعض
لا نشير الى اشتباكات ولكن تستمر هذه
الاصوات ن ستمع ما بين الفينه والاخرى قبل
قليل ايضا سمعنا دوي اصوات من
مضادات طيران ولكن لم نلمح او نرصد اي
حركه او تحليق للطيران الحربي او الطيران
الاستطلاع في هذه اللحظات السيد احمد
مراسلنا من الخرطوم شكرا لك